okay so the nation's being battered by
inflation flooded with illegals and of
course ravaged by crime but what's got
Joe Biden's knickers in a bunch Mr
disarray on Capitol Hill after your
conversation with allies yesterday were
you that you won't be able to deliver
the aid that the U.S has promised to
Ukraine it does worry me and but I know
there are a majority of members of the
House and Senate in both parties
who have said that they support funding
Ukraine the UNA party speaks
he binds new bumper stickers yeah it
looks good
yeah make heave great again
joining me now Ohio Senator JD Vance
Senator I watch this I watch this
Ukraine stuff I'm thinking I'm in New
York a city that I love I used to you
know live here uh years ago when it was
a lot safer but you see the
deteriorating conditions on the streets
here just walking over to the hotel you
see it and and it's everywhere in urban
America and it's spilling over into the
suburbs and what he's most focused on is
to make sure come hell or high water
Ukraine gets what it needs come on
yeah it's really ridiculous Laura and by
the way the American people especially
conservatives are completely fed up with
it you can go through the list of every
single problem the border the fentanyl
problem the crime problem the high
inflation all of these things are far
more important to the American people as
they should be than defending the border
of Ukraine we have to be honest with
ourselves about the corruption in that
country but even if it was a perfect
country there are problems here at home
that deserve our focus and deserve the
attention of the government of this
country what happened last week in both
the house and the Senate should serve as
a wake-up call to the Ukraine first
caucus on Capitol Hill the American
people are over it so there may be some
way Laura for them to try to shove
another 70 or 80 billion dollars in
Ukraine funding down the throats of the
house and the Senate they're going to
have to fight through me to get it done
but more importantly they're going to
have to overcome the frustration of the
American people this is really the the
fight of the next couple of weeks the
uniparty is really going to drive this
Ukraine stuff home people need to wake
up they need to call their congressman
and they need to push back against
putting the interests of a country six
thousand miles away ahead of our own
well Biden doesn't seem to care though
if Congress actually approves more
funding for Ukraine he'll figure out a
way around it
not additional funding how long will the
United States be able to support Ukraine
we can
support Ukraine in the next tranche we
need and there is another means by which
we may be able to
find funding for that but I'm not going
to get into that now
wait should we expect more accounting
errors on the horizon remember that
little trick they pulled uh
Senator Vance the people of America
couldn't get it couldn't get via Trump
five billion dollars to secure our
border with a wall
but this guy's like oh no do we got we
got Tricks Up Our Sleeve for Ukraine I
mean they can always fund the money for
Ukraine find it somewhere they'll find
it come hell or high water could this be
by the way a a benefit that maybe will
come out of a difficult situation in the
house with the ouster of McCarthy could
this end up hurting the Ukraine first
caucus
well Laura first of all I don't know
whether to laugh or cry you have the
president United States issuing a slap
in the face of constitutional governance
Congress gets to decide what to do with
the American people's money he enforces
the laws he doesn't write the
Appropriations bills himself it's really
disgraceful to hear the president talk
like that but part of the reason why
he's able to do it and this goes to your
question about the house Laura is for
too long Congress has failed to provide
proper oversight of what is
fundamentally a a one-party actor in
Washington DC that is changing though I
think a lot of the shake up in the house
has sent a message to people that
Congress is not going to give a blank
check to Ukraine funding and they're not
going to give a blank check to the by
demonstration that's a good message to
send but we got to keep hammering it
Laura because the next three weeks are
really when we win or lose this battle
now
um who are you looking at from the
Senate side who would you like to see as
the next speaker
well Laura you know none of my business
I'm a senator the house guys are going
to figure it out I of course love Jim
Jordan the great congressman from the
state of Ohio a good friend of mine and
I I I hope that whoever the house
selects and I'm certainly back in gym
that it's a person who puts the
interests of our Citizens first we so
desperately need a house speaker that is
a counterbalance to Joe Biden not a
rubber stamp I think Jim Jordan would do
that job of course there are others who
would do that job too we'll let the
house figure it out all right Senator
Vance thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else